bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo episodio dio che vi
racconto i cazzi miei che teoricamente
non fregano nessuno però io ve lo dico
allora ragazzi oggi vi racconterò quella
storiella che non so neanche come
nominare in realtà del sole ci penso
però la vera racconta lo stesso siamo in
giappone ci siamo io e d'errico
gianandrea per chi non lo sapesse usare
andrea siamo dati in giappone l'anno
scorso abbia fatto il viaggio quello che
io reputo il più bello di tutta la mia
vita perché andare in giappone perché
non solo siamo andati il giappone
normalmente quindi a tokyo dove siamo
stati a totti e basta sembrati proprio
in giappone abbiamo fatto un viaggio
itinerario abbiamo fatto il giro di
tutto il giappone dopo due giorni che
eravamo già giochi in acqua in spiaggia
perché dice la spiaggia dove chiara poco
frenata c'era veramente poca gente
perché non era neanche un periodo di
vacanza incontriamo delle persone e tra
queste c'era anche una ragazza ragazza
abbastanza carina in realtà è già aveva
fatto il passetto in più ma poi insomma
chiacchiera non ama la veloce proprio
chiacchierano un attimo allora io dico
già già bye bye attacco usa turbo fuoco
niente jean è andato dalla tipa ne hanno
parlottato qualcosa come 60 secondi poi
torna torna da me jean grey che è
successo semplicemente mi ha detto che
lei non è di questa zona qua sta andando
via
però domani sera non ha niente da fare
mi ha invitato nella sua zona a mangiare
qualcosa e io fighissimo bravo grazie
grazie quindi quando è che andiamo
domani ci vai tu a un appuntamento è tuo
ma no dai lo riaccompagna mica una cosa
[ __ ] e io
il giorno dopo la cena prendiamo questo
taxi allora voi dovete sapere che
abbinava è veramente piccola quindi già
aver già prendere un taxi era
impossibile digiuno trova un taxi in
quell'isola impossibile riusciamo a
prendere un taxi sta ragazza abitava
dall'altra parte dell'isola
la tv aveva dato indicazioni a jean di
fermarsi in una certa via ci fermiamo
ragazzi avete avete mai giocato a
residenti va al 5 quando parte c'è
quello rodata di zombie e ci sono tutte
quelle bancarelle abbandonate ecco il e
quella cittadina il cavo era così c'era
abbandonata non c'era nessuno e noi
scendiamo letteralmente davanti a una
base militare americana dei marines ad
okinawa in giappone rauti povera e gia
in questa cosa ha preso per il culo se
adesso esce un marina ci prende a
cazzotti in bocca
invece dopo un minuto arriva la tipa
tutta presa bene vede che ci sono anche
io cioè che cazzo avrà pensato ma chi è
questo ci prende a braccetto entrambi
tutta contenta e ci dirigiamo a cena al
samah chiacchieriamo finisce la cena
andiamo
in un pub dove si faceva anche il
karaoke ok niente la tipa ci invita
perché in giappone si usa moltissimo
fare carosio gay la tipa ci invita a
cantare quindi già la serata sta
volgendo nel kring io mi propongo
beatamente per cantare con lei visto che
parlando di uscito fuori che lo
conosceva anche lei high school musical
high school musical ragazzi breaking
free e io ho cantato con questa ragazza
breaking free di high school musical
comunque faccio questa precisazione
perchè molto importante io quando vado
in giro non parlo mai del mio la voce
quando incontra una persona che non mi
conosce non sa chi sono io non parlo di
youtube di niente pensano poi sempre la
stessa cosa fai
come funziona massì famoso incredibile e
quindi per evitare che si scorsi tutte
le volte io evito di dire che faccio
youtuber non dico niente deve
semplicemente diverso
beh insomma si va a questo farsi carta
esco il musical dopo un po entrano in
cui eravamo in questo barbera e vengono
precisato eravamo io già andrea è questa
ragazza e basta e vangelis la barista e
basta non c'era nessuno dopo un po
entrano in questo pub tre marines degli
stati uniti vedono altre marine
statunitensi tutti uno più grosso
dell'altro sembrano the rock e si
siedono e io già li sentivo un po di una
situazione un po tesa perché comunque se
ci pensi l'okinawa un'isola dove non c'è
nessuno ce lo stima rings che saranno
invogliati come dei cani perché adesso
ci penso e dico ma
chiamano mai quindi dico già c'è solo
una ragazza carina in tutta la contea
della sta portando via jan quindi ho
detto qua jean muore ma certo punto jean
va in bagno
questo cede link jean va in bagno mentre
giammai in bagno io ero lì c'era anche
l'asl at iva
già che c'era mi parlottiamo un attimino
e mi chiede il tipo il profilo instagram
invase team a coletto instagram
guarda questo scrive che posso
inventarmi una cazzata falli j
la tipa col telefono si è favi j la sua
faccia questa wait wait wait guys
comverse disguise space marines si
alzano tutti uno più grosso dell'altro
corrono è in un secondo mi sono
ritrovato accerchiato dalla tipa che si
stava rimorchiando già dalla barista e
dai tre marin e c'ero io in mezzo come
funziona cosa fa chi studia dove buco
tutte ste casini lo jan esce dal dal
bagno come uscito a vista in un secondo
ha capito la situazione tua fan gulas
vabbè che comunque c'era già shamo dal
pub andiamo in un altro pub un po più
malfamato nostro spiega bob gangster e
mi fanno miei cambi tasca with us
e noi siamo andati etero in questo pub
c'era un tavolo da biliardo e avevano
ragazzi avevano un xbox one con tekken e
mi fanno gli who played with us with the
game
ma cosa io mi metto a giocare con uno di
loro mi fa un culo così perché io non
ero bravo a tekken e dopo che mi batte
arriva un suo amico mi guarda guarda
l'altro marinelli dice all'altro marin
se adesso lui indicando menti batte mi
devi 100 dollari
quindi io mi sono messo a sfidare uno
con il rischio di farli perdere il 100
dollari perché lui ha scommesso 100 la
tav e che ha visto che non erano bravi
e che quindi non li perderà mai 100
dollari ragazzi alla meglio di tre primo
round vince lui il secondo round vince
lui e le mancava uno ragazzi da 2 a 0 a
2 a 1 2 a 2
alla fine rava tanto così di vita 3 a 2
lo battuto e corri ha dovuto dare 100
dollari all'altro marin perché io ho
fatto un culo così
e non so come ho fatto a batterlo perchè
che si erano anche abbastanza barabini
censi faccio pagare il confronto ho
fatto per le 100 dollari o marin a caso
abbiamo fatto per tornare a casa già non
passava un taxi di pomeriggio
manco a pagarlo la sera era introvabile
quindi noi abbiamo rischiato di dormire
fuori ma fuori per strada ad okinawa
perché non si trovavano taxi per tornare
il tel dopo mille ore siamo riuscito a
trovare un gatto i taxi a tornare a casa
tardissimo ad esaminati in hotel tipo
alle 2 3 di notte e ci siamo buttati a
dormire perché con la ragazza comunque
alla fine già non ci ha concluso una
sega perché alla fine l'attenzione si è
spostata sulla combriccola che giocava
quindi già non è riuscito a concludere
una sega alla fine abbiamo gli hotel
stremati e le tre di notte ci picchiamo
nel letto io ho fatto perdere 100
dollari o marin o ho conquistato la
gloria tutto contento e gianni non ha
chiamato storici l'okinawa wow
bellissimo non mi storo non vi racconto
malato alimentata in realtà è vero poi
abbiamo fatto anche una partitina
biliardo già che c'eravamo è quel video
tra l'altro
[Applauso]
basta che poi basta basta i ricordi il
copyright dei green bay ragazzi
[Musica]